- You've been a bad boy,
Lloyd.
You ate the forbidden fruit.
Now you shall be...cast into
the valley of employment.
Bye-bye.
- Harsher, Grace.
I want this to hurt him
personally.
- [sighs]
You fucked up, Lloyd!
You got greedy
with the fucking pinkies.
[bleep] fired.
- Alright,
we're getting somewhere.
- Should we reward ourselves?
- To justice being served.
- Some people are weak,
and I say let 'em die.
[gagging]
- Mm. So good.
Are you choking?
I don't know CPR.
Um, I'm gonna Google it.
- [grunts]
- Uh, the Wi-Fi is being shitty.
- ♪
- I'm just gonna film this.
- [heartbeat pounding]
- GRACE: [muffled]
Jake.
Don't make that face.
- [camera clicks]
- [heartbeat pounding]
- ♪ I found love ♪
♪ Didn't even know
I needed it ♪
♪ But I found love ♪
♪ Never even
crossed my mind ♪
- You gotta be careful
with those pinkies.
I get it though.
They're the best ones.
Take it easy.
- It's not CPR.
It's the Heimlich.
- Oh yeah.
I don't know how
to do that one either.